on va en parler sébastien avec gérald
dans une seconde de cette cote de crédit
du québec mais d'abord restons à québec
et dans le jeu politique
madame marois et monsieur blanchet son
mari sont invités entre guillemets à une
commission parlementaire le 10 mars au
retour des travaux de l'assemblée
nationale pas sûr qu'ils y seront au
fait il est tout indique qu'il n'y
seront pas parce que aujourd'hui la
commission parlementaire qui les
convoque devaient se réunir en réunion
de travail pour déterminer le calendrier
est peut-être convoqué madame marois et
monsieur blanchet le 10 mars au retour
des deux semaines de relâche
parlementaire
or les péquistes ne se sont pas
présentés à cette réunion de travail si
bien que pendant les deux prochaines
semaines la commission ne peut pas se
réunir à cause d'un blocage
parlementaire et la prochaine réunion
n'est prévue que le 10 mars prochain le
10 mars
si la commission décide de convoquer mal
à maroua monsieur blanchet il faut leur
donner deux semaines de préavis pour les
convoquer si bien que madame marois
monsieur blanchet témoignerait deux
semaines plus tard longtemps après que
madame marois et déclencher des
élections parce qu'on pense que ce
serait le 11 et 12 mars et si elle
déclenche des élections
ben il y aura pas de témoignage devant
la commission parlementaire reste que je
vous épargne les mots qu'on m'a donnée
pour décrire l'état d'esprit de madame
marois
ça ne se répète pas en ondes mais on
parle de basse politique de mesquinerie
d' attaques personnelles de vengeance
aussi à l'égard du couple marois
blanchet écoutant quelques commentaires
la première ministre veut se défiler de
ses responsabilités non seulement se
défiler de ses responsabilités c'est
qu'elle défie un ordre de la chambre et
dans l'histoire du québec à l'assemblée
nationale ce n'est jamais arrivé tous
les premiers ministres ont accepté de
comparaître en commission parlementaire
pour ma part je suis convaincu qu'il ya
anguille sous roche je pense de plus en
plus une mode observateur au québec
actuellement ils vont tenter de faire
tous les amalgames pauvres
pour montrer que finalement ils sont
totalement désorganisés désorientés
l'autre choix aurait été d'y aller et de
laisser les gens jugés mais bref comment
soulager en campagne électorale
finalement exactement bons parlant de
campagne électorale tous les partis
mettent la touche finale à leur candidat
c'est loin d'être réglé les gens pensent
que si tout régler on chasse à droite et
à gauche et entre autres martin
desjardins pour le parti québécois
oui l'ancien président de la fédération
étudiante universitaire qu'on a appris à
connaître dans le conflit étudiants qui
est devenue chroniqueuse politique
depuis elle a été approchée elle a une
offre sur la table pour se présenter
pour le parti québécois
elle est en réflexion dans mon sport
n'est pas de circonscription qui a été
identifiée pour madame desjardins elle
devrait donner une réponse dans pas très
longtemps au pq si vous pensez que le
parti québécois va être trois en trois
avec les leaders étudiants après léo
bureau blouin et martine desjardins fait
une croix sur gabriel nadeau-dubois on
pense plutôt qu'il a plus d'affinités
avec québec solidaire qu'avec le pays qu
on le croit aussi aimé il qui se
présenterait pas aux prochaines
élections par contre voilà deux sur
trois voilà deux seront possiblement il
se serait pas dans mille et laval
c'était là la grosse crise que nos
sources nous disent aussi mais il faut
deux circonscriptions défini ou de
préparer de présenter à madame
desjardins ben voilà ça va être ça au
cours des prochains jours sébastien
merci aujourd'hui comment la prochaine
au revoir